-♪ You can let it
wreck your day ♪
♪ You can pray that
it goes away ♪
♪ Or let something wild and
wonderful break through ♪
♪ We're ripping up
the recipe ♪
♪ Let go of how it has to be ♪
♪ You know you can't
plan it in advance ♪
♪ Gotta lose yourself
in the dance ♪
♪ It's perfect unexpectedly ♪
-Mom?
-♪ when you rip up the recipe ♪
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Constance Wu!
That was a clip from her new
movie, "Lyle, Lyle, Crocodile."
And you were just telling me,
that is a real crocodile.
That is not...
-Mm-hmm.
-That was really good.
-Yep.
-You must have had a lot of
faith in the trainer on set.
-Well, I actually wanted to
play the crocodile,
but then they said, "No,
we're having the real thing."
-Well, this is
your current headshot.
-Yeah.
-So this is very exciting,
to do --
I would imagine doing
a family film like this
is more exciting when you
yourself have a family.
One of the differences since
the last time we saw you,
you have a two-year-old.
Congratulations.
-I had a baby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Thank you.
-Now, will she be able to watch?
Will you show her this film, or
is she still a little too young?
-I feel like I'm gonna just
go straight to "Hustlers."
-Yeah, I think "Hustlers."
-Show her that.
Show her the good career path.
This is the real me.
-This is a movie about
making money.
-[ Laughter ]
Well, I mean, I will --
I don't care.
She can watch "Hustlers,"
but not now.
She can't even sit still
for more than, like, 5 minutes.
-Yeah, that's the thing.
It's not really about
whether they're appropriate.
They just have no interest.
-Yeah.
She's just, like, running around
all over the place.
But she loves animal,
so, you know?
-I think eventually,
this is gonna be a hit.
-I hope so.
-I wondered,
because we still have
our pet dog that we had
before we had kids.
I don't feel proud of this,
but we do pay less attention
to our dog
now that we have children.
Do you still have your rabbit?
-I don't even remember.
I've completely abandoned her.
Just kidding. Just kidding.
[ Laughter ]
No, this is a recent picture.
-Oh, good.
So she's still with you.
-Yeah.
She's like
a little, old lady now.
-Yeah.
-What's her name again?
-Her name is Lida Rose.
-Lida Rose?
-Yeah.
-That's a beautiful name.
-Thank you.
-A little much for a rabbit.
-Not for her.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Now, you mentioned that
she's sort of
a grand dame now of rabbits.
And you think
she looks like someone.
-Yes, well, last time
we were on here,
I was like,
"She resembles Jeremy Irons."
-You did say that.
-But now that she's aged...
-She's aged out of Jeremy Irons.
-I really, truly think
she looks like --
[ Laughter ]
-It does look like Maggie.
It's a dowager countess look.
-It is. I've just got to put a
hat on her and she's there.
-[ Laughter ]
-You know?
-It's really quite something.
Does your daughter have
any interest in the rabbit?
-For about a minute.
-Yeah.
The way she has interest in
everything for about a minute.
-Gotcha.
-But yeah.
-Does the rabbit tense up
when the baby comes around?
'Cause our dog has not warmed up
to our young err children.
-My rabbit, if you pet her
on the head --
she loves being pet, like,
right here --
she doesn't care, she loves you.
-Oh, great.
-And then if you don't,
she's just like,
"I don't care about you,"
and she just goes away.
-Well, you know what?
She knows what she likes.
-She knows what she wants, yep.
-Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
I really appreciate you
making the time,
sharing your stories,
and it's always such a pleasure
to see you.
-Thank you.
-Congrats on your movie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Constance Wu, everybody.
"Lyle, Lyle, Crocodile" is
in theaters this Friday.
"Making a Scene," right here,
is on sale now
wherever books are sold.
Please support local
and independent bookstores.
We'll be right back
with Ramy Youssef.